[Music]
so we'll keep an eye on these guys and
see where they go is they probably gonna
go to their nets which are somewhere out
here
the crew of this ship is on a mission to
try and save one of the most endangered
sea creatures on the planet we now our
night-vision drone setup is line and
close they're in the middle of a marine
protected area in Mexico a conservation
zone where certain types of fishing are
banned two guys covering their faces I'm
pretty sure they're pulling a net local
fishermen are poaching a species of fish
that is so highly prized in China they
can make tens of thousands of dollars in
just one night he's got a gun he's got a
gun gun gun we now know that these guys
have guns
think for the safety of the drone I'm
gonna fly home now we have the
coordinates marked of where that now was
tomorrow we're gonna pick up that net
even though this is a marine protected
area the illegal fishermen still will go
out and poach they will destroy this
ecosystem and we're here to try starting
with ocean life under threat could
marine protected areas be the answer
sixteen meters of line in the water near
the Mexican fishing town of San Felipe
on the upper Gulf of California
conservation group Sea Shepherd is
working with the authorities to help
enforce a marine protected area or MPA a
designated section of ocean to be
conserved managed and protected
most of the damage caused for human
activity is done by the coast where the
highest biodiversity can be fine
maintaining rich diverse ecosystems is
key for the health of the ocean and
ultimately the survival of humanity but
ocean life is under threat from plants
to microorganisms and animals species
are disappearing forever marine
protected areas of the west rule we have
to protect and conserve biodiversity
from the in from the human impact marine
biologist
Patricia Gandolfo and the rest of the
sea Shepherd crew are here to stop
poachers caught up in the nets of the
criminal gangs and local fishermen is
one particularly rare porpoise the
vaquita
you cannot find potatoes anywhere else
in the world the v-system 8 is between
10 and 30 the makitas left eye so low
that if we don't do anything we will
lose them forever worldwide there are
thousands of sea species currently
threatened with extinction losing just
one species from the food chain can have
a disastrous effect on an entire
ecosystem
this kind of nets are forbidden now we
can find up to 13 Nets in a day when you
find a net first order it is like no
animals in the net I'm of course not
rakita there's something tangled in the
net
[Music]
it's a dead Toto ABBA
the endangered and highly valued fish
the poachers are after so there's a
clear example of how these nets can here
so these fees can be worth up to five
thousand dollars just for the fishermen
after it's sold on the toto Abbas swim
bladder can fetch up to a hundred
thousand dollars a kilo in China where
its prized for its medicinal properties
all I want is the yes
where's me I'm losing control oh we're
not ready to follow the toto a burn
needs to be destroyed
Patricia calls in the Mexican Navy and
the environmental agency who are
patrolling the area
[Music]
[Music]
critics disapprove of Sea Shepherd's use
of direct action tactics in some of
their campaigns but in the Gulf of
California their presence is welcomed by
the Mexican government the sepal is
working with the Mexican environmental
agencies and the Navy fighting against
illegal fishing but that is not going to
be successful until the local
communities agree to work with us and
stop this illegal activity in the marine
protected area globally the fishing
industry employs 260 million people but
many more subsistence fishermen depend
on the ocean for their income local
fishermen here claim protecting the
ocean has limited how they can fish
destroying their way of life yet doing
nothing may ultimately present more of a
threat to their livelihoods
800 miles south from the turmoil
unfolding in San Felipe lies the once
thriving fishing village of cabo pulmo
David Castro's family worked these
waters for decades until overfishing
destroyed their livelihoods he would own
a comet or to employ spaces dependence
on a llegar al punto de comer TLRs if
ananda cierto submarine que era salir
Alomar 1/3 a cup - Rahr peasant Montaner
no he died basically no croissants in
solo person in a launch a new era era
era fruit rent a para para mi familia
in order to survive the community
decided to try something new
conservation they approach the Mexican
government to help them transform cabo
pulmo into a marine protected area
strict conservation rules were put in
place and enforced by local residents to
protect populations of fish and other
sea life commercial fishing was banned
and scientists were invited in to
monitor the reef kokumo for lead has a
very special place in my heart I feel
very happy marine biologist professor
Octavio Aburto has been studying cabo
pulmo for over 20 years I believe this
is one of the most important marine
protected areas around the world which
are Marine Park that was established in
1995 2010
nobody has fish inside the park
Octavio hasn't been here for a year and
he's excited to see what's happened in
that time today Octavio is going out to
survey a reef
let's go
cabo pulmo marine protected area is only
27 square miles it's tiny
but 22 years after the no fishing policy
was introduced it's having an effect on
a far greater area the ideal for marine
protected area is very simple the dip
the ocean arrest and everything that was
exploited will recover then when animals
start growing and the abundances start
increasing all these animals and all
these new babies will start going out
from the area it's an effect that is
called the spillover effect
[Music]
what's happening in these waters is
attracting global attention
[Music]
we have been monitoring the series for
the last ten years the first time that I
came I didn't see anything that the ribs
were empty every time that we do a
transit fearing cover problem we see
more and more fish compared with other
ribs
Octavio is here to measure the size of
the fish and record species that are new
to the reef when I'd put my regulator in
my mouth and I jump in the water
everything changes for me I forget about
what is happening on LAN the time
somebody stopped
[Music]
thirty minutes into his dive octavio
spots a group of surprise visitors
a school of bull sharks
[Music]
for most people this would be terrifying
but for Octavio it's a sight he's been
waiting for since the creation of cabo
pulmo z-- marine protected area over 20
years ago
[Music]
[Music]
all dive twelve sharks with us
incredible sharks are the most important
species in the rich because they control
the praise they remove the sick animals
they're the old ones
so we charged the marine communities are
more productive
currently marine protected areas make up
only 3.6 percent of the world's ocean
but a growing number of scientists are
calling for 30 percent to be protected
by 2030
the 22 years of protection their
community mie community as rebound
amazingly it's almost 500% in Bahamas
that it's that means more fish and
bigger bigger fish especially chopper
[Music]
cabo pulmo now has a thriving ecotourism
and diving industry the environmental
rewards provided by the MPA to the local
community have been valued at millions
of dollars a year far more than they
ever made from fishing for me their
success of this marine protected area is
because the community requested the
National Park they have been involved in
many activities including enforcement
they are receiving the economic benefits
of this production now more and more
people come to see the reefs to see the
Sharks and this money is basically
increasing the human well-being of
everyone that lives here in California
conservation has changed David's life
forever
Posadas event a videographer notable
demos los resultados cow uma Rasta
simple center Cooper Asim poor Sentosa
Louisville y la vie de la comunidad
cambio no cambio para VN porque ahora
severe math curriculum Anthea the
scientific research taking place at capo
Palma is providing hope that other
destroyed marine habitats can recover I
think that the cabo pulmo community was
able to recover this fantastic marine
life there should be no problem for
other communities in other parts of the
world to recover the oceans in the same
way
cabo pulmo is just a short flight from
america it can work as an eco resort
because it's accessible for tourists but
most coastal communities that rely on
fishing are so remote they will never be
able to make this kind of marine
protected area a reality the village of
and avid work is on the remote
southwestern coast of Madagascar
it's home to the vaso people who like
nearly 90 percent of the population here
a small-scale fishermen more than 3
billion people depend on the ocean for
their primary source of protein Russa is
one of them not a local area before
moving a system and eel is a map and
Anthony Sanders announced about
subtracting a low point
the ocean is ingrained in ruses culture
surveys say monkeys are fun haha mullet
invasion violin octopus involves are
havin such a mood invisible me a
camellia Covanta white octopuses thrive
in these coastal waters but as foreign
demand for octopuses grew fishing
communities like ruses were encouraged
to increase their catch
it was unsustainable octopus stocks were
soon in drastic decline local fishing
people him they'd never foreseen that
they one day they would struggle to feed
their children dr. Garth crypts works
for the charity blue ventures in 2006 it
helped launch Madagascar's first locally
managed marine area a type of MPA
despite its depending on the scene the
Vezina have previously had no right
students
so the key thing that enabled them to
survive was completely unsecured and it
was open access anybody could come in
and push a total fishing ban wasn't an
option so blue ventures offered an
innovative plan smaller temporary bands
for a set number of months acting like a
crop rotation in coastal waters this
enables stocks to replenish themselves
while allowing the community to continue
fishing sustainably zeramy valley samba
mila holy Donnelly hue it's a big day
for rooster in the community this is the
first time they've been allowed to fish
for octopuses in two months
meet automatically de la face on Mimi
Hilda not a Volvo if I tell you later
for the battle over happiness you who
lead I suppose more little mischievous
passivity Putin became human
- ah tonight on gobbler
[Music]
the locally managed marine areas are
patrolled by the villagers themselves
who impose strict rules now Thorazine
verso who detail miss Opoku Lulu tens a
LOF a miss me jus being a pharmacist
Kimberly back from the parents death of
Assad
[Music]
these types of MPAs have been such a
success they're being rolled out across
the country I kind of see Holly a I kind
of see my man who's that read that
thanks to seasonal closures which give
octopuses extra time to grow ruses catch
has increased in size and she now owns
nearly 90 percent more at market gaming
5v lisa diluent re calle and gamma plaza
media - sierra mommy cafe the octopuses
will be taken to a processing plant to
be frozen and shipped off to restaurants
in Europe Africa and Asia with more than
65 locally managed marine areas have now
sprung up on the island dr. Fernau
receptacle valencia k2 e denomination RZ
today at aloha lion therapy booming
poodles i Kokua for now these locally
managed areas are replenishing coastal
waters but beyond the horizon there's a
far bigger threat over which the baizhu
have no control it's subsidized foreign
industrial fishing that is draining our
seas the capacity of a single industrial
vessel is the equivalent to what this
fishing community catches in an entire
year
we need to act drastically and urgent
otherwise refacing immeasurable loss of
life in our oceans while most damage
from overfishing happens around the
coast in order to ensure the planets
biodiversity scientists are also looking
to protect large swathe of marine
habitats including those in the high
seas
the ocean covers around 70% of the
Earth's surface the challenge is
policing the most remote waters on the
planet
the answer may lie in an unlikely
location a team in central England
believes it has the solution to policing
the high seas what we're looking at
right now is a map of the world all
these little dots these triangles that
you see represent hundreds of thousands
of vessels cruise tracking systems we
can pick up with satellites Bradley
Sewell is a fishing analyst working for
ocean mind a not-for-profit organisation
harnessing the power of satellite
technology to fight against illegal
fishing satellite surveillance is one of
the most cost effective ways to monitor
remote marine protected areas and ensure
that vessels operating in the area are
following the rules globally there are
more than four million fishing vessels
the biggest are fitted with tracking
systems known as a is or automatic
identification system this technology is
a game-changer for fishing enforcement
vessels change course and speed
to set their fishing gear and to pull it
out of the water and these courses and
speeds when looked at over time can give
you a really strong sense of whether or
not it was just transiting through the
area or maybe what type of fishing
activity may have been taking place this
technology enables the team here to keep
tabs on commercial ships
especially when they're passing through
marine protected areas ocean mind is
currently working with governments from
all over the world to help reduce the
amount of illegally caught fish valued
at around twenty three billion dollars
each year Thailand is one of them we are
in the process of helping the Thai
government to see if there are any risk
indicators of illegally caught fish
entering supply chains inside Thailand
Bangkok is one of the busiest tuna ports
in the world
Natalie tail right is ocean mines
representative on the ground
she works alongside the Thai port
authorities any foreign flagged fishing
vessel wanting to unload its catch is
investigated using tracking data
gathered by ocean mind so with the track
analysis the ocean mind has done for one
of the carrier vessels we've highlighted
that the vessel may have had slow speeds
on the high seas the red dots here
indicate speeds below 5 knots and this
is an indicator of possible fishing
activity
natalie has given these findings to the
Thai port authorities they have the
power to inspect vessels question the
captain and investigate logbooks during
their investigation if they found the
catch was illegally caught they wouldn't
let the vessel offload and that would
prevent the illegal catch from entering
the supply chain
some of these 200 ton vessels can carry
their own weight in fish if a ship's
captain cannot prove the catch is legal
they won't be able to unload making
their haul worthless morning
splashing lysis and then the clasp shake
with the navigation lock what you're
seeing now is this vessel unloading tuna
because it's it's past the the
inspections these types of ports take
checks are reducing opportunities for
illegally caught fish to be landed and
enter the seafood supply chain which is
fantastic news for ocean conservation
because it means that it's harder for
illegally caught fish that's potentially
caught in a marine protected area to be
landed and so
marker new technology is allowing the
ocean to be monitored in a practical and
affordable way providing the first real
hope of enforcing high sea marine
protected areas and fighting illegal
fishing globally this type of work that
we're doing if that was multiplied
across the largest ports in the world
the impact would be tremendous in terms
of ocean conservation
but technology alone won't save the
ocean
[Music]
back in Mexico marine biologist
professor Octavio Aburto is making his
last dive of the day on the cabo pulmo
reef
[Music]
our ocean is facing its greatest ever
challenge overfishing pollution and
climate change are all threatening the
health of a resource on which the whole
world depends we are losing a lot of
species we are losing a lot of
ecosystems and many coastal communities
also are losing the resources to survive
so we must act now if we want to recover
and protect the oceans and help the
people that depend on these resources
[Music]
marine protected areas can come in many
forms but if they are to be effective
they must align the need for
conservation with the needs of those who
depend on the ocean for survival in
order to avoid disaster and to ensure a
sustainable supply of fish for the
future far more of our ocean needs
urgent protection
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you